I'm sure you're asked about this scene
constantly but the interrogation scene
from menace to society I was bring you
could just I know this is a probably
you've Advan asked this question so much
but if you could just take us back to
that day just doing that scene what was
it like for you I just finished doing a
film I would think it was in Canada and
acting in the film and I rushed back and
at the same day that I came in I had to
be on the set the Hughes brothers and I
guess but their work I'm like who they
were I read the script and I loved it
it was only one scene and it's like the
way they set it up got me immediately
into the mood because the room was dark
except there were like three spotlights
one on the young boy one in the middle
of the table the gun was and one on
myself and everything else was in shadow
and the police had brought this young
man into this place to intimidate him
into telling the truth and so he was
sitting there really nervous you know
they thought he was smarter than
everybody in the in the room and so when
I questioned him it was like I first
brought the gun in put on the table and
turned it toward him but said to him
you're not necessarily getting out of
here alive
there's nothing you can do about it what
do we can all say that she reached for
the gun and we defended ourselves in
charge we did sales words we just won
like that that was that belt said that
said it when he saw that it was like oh
boy okay and we started asking questions
ask some questions about was he there
and he said no and
he said you left the beer here and you
bought the beer at this time you drank
the beer at this time then he was his I
saw his hands start shaking and then I
asked him the same question again and he
man the second time said a different
time and that's when I knew that I had
him and you know that little gang
thought they were so smart and we were
so stupid it was a number it was a it
was a feeling of joy when I said to him
you know something [ __ ] [ __ ] up right
no no no no nothing you know you done
[ __ ] up right now here's what's crazy
I was in Brussels Belgium around five or
six months ago acting in afula Nicolas
Cage calm Andy right uh I'm sitting in a
restaurant eating food by myself
this young building kid comes up to me
and says you choose me sure but you know
you don't [ __ ] up right
I laughed so hard but no matter what
country I go to I mean I've made a lot
of films as an actor and director and
the line that said to me the most around
the world no matter what city I cook
over and you know something
they're young kids that's what's amazing
to me they've all seen that picture I
don't know how they see it
but they see it Leo I'll repeat that
line and older people too so yes it's
it's it's interesting how has that
impacted your life I'm sure it's got to
feel good that people know your work yes
at the same time maybe you're surprised
that they're young kids that are seeing
this film
from all walks of life what does that
mitt do to someone what it means you did
a good job because you impacted them in
that way you also wished there is the
more than [ __ ] they remember you for
than just that line but you know your
preach it till it the fact that they've
seen your work and they appreciate what
you've done and that it's always good
you know because I'm very self-critical
in my work and so when someone affirms
that what I've done impacted them that's
a very rewarding it's very order so they
don't have to be kind they don't have to
come up to you they don't have to what
they do at a certain age you think you
think you've been forgotten about you
haven't that's she worrying also
especially when young people do it in
different countries
you